hi my name is Michael Aaron I'm an
engineer on the Android development team
Android is an open software platform for
mobile development it is intended to be
a complete stack that includes
everything from the operating system
through middleware and up through
applications now I'm going to talk about
how Android can achieve smooth
integration of components that are
written by different authors as user
navigates forward and backward through
the experience in Android every
application runs in its own process
there's a lot of benefits to this it
gives you security protected memory it
means that an application that's doing
something CPU intensive won't block
other critical activities like answering
the phone
so all applications are running in their
own processes and the Android system
itself is responsible for starting these
processes and shutting them down as
necessary to reclaim resources I have an
example that shows how that works now to
explain this example let me set up the
scenario in this example the user is
going to navigate from the home screen
to their inbox in the mail application
they're going to select a mail message
from the mail message they're going to
follow a link out to some web content in
the browser and then from the browser
they're going to click on something that
takes them into the Maps application
which is a not unreasonable scenario now
when they do this they're going to
actually navigate through four different
applications running in four different
processes that are potentially written
by four different authors from the users
point of view none of that is important
what they want is to be able to navigate
forward clicking on what they want to
click on getting the component they want
to have responding to each click and
then they want to be able to go
backwards and get back to where they
were and in particular they don't want
to have to worry about which
applications are running how much memory
they've consumed how much memory is left
on the device whether they can launch
that next process because all the
resources have been taken up so the
Android system manages all that for them
here's how it works
at the start the user is on the home
page there are two processes in this
example that are running there's the
system process which contains the
activity manager that contains the
common back stack that is used by all
activities
regardless of which process they run in
and then the home process is running and
that has the home activity running
inside it now before launching the mail
application the system is going to save
the state of the home application just
in case anything bad happens to it and
you'll see that bad stuff in a few
minutes so the home application has
saved its state in a little parcel that
is been moved to the system process and
at that point the system can create the
mail process we can then launch the mail
list activity into that process and now
that's what the user is seeing on the
screen their mail list if they click on
a particular mail message then that
creates a request to launch the next
activity that goes to the system process
again before a new activity is launched
we save the state of the last activity
so the mail list saves its state into
the system process it's worth noting
that the state that it saves is not
every message in your Inbox
it's meta information about the current
state of the activity things like where
you are scrolled to in the list which
item is selected you don't have to store
the complete mail list in that parcel so
now that the information has been saved
then the system is free to launch the
next activity that shows a particular
mail message and now that is what the
user sees on the screen from the mail
message they then click on a link to go
out to the web so again another request
is created the state of the currently
running activity is saved in the system
process and now we need to create a
process to run the browser in so we
launch the browser process we launch the
browser activity into that process and
the user is now looking at the browser
we're going to do this one more time
where the user clicks on a link in the
browser to launch a map we create the
request we save the state of the
foreground activity in this case the
browser and we would like to launch the
Maps application but as you can see
we're out of room so
in order to launch the Maps application
we have to find a process that we can
kill we don't want to kill the home
application because we use that for a
navigation hub we want that to be always
available so it's always responsive we
don't want to kill the browser because
that's the activity the user just came
from but the mail application is a few
frames back on the back stack no one's
looking at it it's a perfect candidate
to kill and so it's gone now that the
mail application is gone we can create
the Maps process and in the Maps process
we can create the Maps activity and now
the user is looking at the map so it's
worth noting that all of this happened
without the user being aware of any of
the machinery from the users point of
view they clicked on mail they went to
mail they clicked on a message they went
to a message they clicked from the
message to the web they went to the web
from the web they clicked on a map they
went to a map the fact that these are
different processes different
applications different developers it's
invisible to the user which is as it
should be now the reason we saved all
those little pieces of state information
in the system process is so that we can
go backwards and the user can navigate
backwards as seamlessly as they
navigated forward so from the current
state if the user hits back the first
thing that we're going to do is pop the
Maps application off the top of the
activity stack and restore the browser
the browser doesn't actually need to
restore its state because it's the same
object so at this point we can just
discard the saved state that was stored
in the system process and now the user
is looking at the browser that's the
foreground activity if they hit back
again they are expecting to go back to
the mail message that they came from
unfortunately the mail process isn't
running anymore so the first thing we
have to do is make space to run the mail
application we do that by killing the
Maps process and starting the mail
process once we've done that we can then
launch a fresh copy of the message
activity this is a new copy that doesn't
have any of the state that the user saw
when they left in order to get it back
into the state that the user is
expecting we then take that save part
full of information from the system
process and we restore the state of the
message activity once we've done that is
ready to be shown to the user we can pop
the browser off the top of the activity
stack show them the message activity and
they're back where they started if we do
that one more time if we hit back again
from the mail message to go back to the
mail list we don't have to create a new
process because this one is still
running in the mail process we just
create a new instance of the mail list
activity that again is a fresh activity
to restore its state we take the state
from the system process give that back
to the mail list now the mail list is in
the same state that it was when the user
left we can pop the message and the user
is back where they came from so the what
this example is showing is that the user
can navigate forwards and backwards
through multiple activities that run
multiple processes that are provided by
multiple developers and have a very
seamless experience because the AMBER
Alert framework is doing the hard work
of launching and shutting down processes
to manage resources and making sure that
the state is preserved as user expects
if you're interested in finding out more
about Android I encourage you to visit
the developer site and download the SDK
in the SDK you'll find a lot more
documentation and sample code and you
will also be able to try building
applications of your own there's also a
developer group that you can join to
find out more information and I also
encourage you to check back frequently
because we'll be posting updates to the
SDK as the platform matures thank you
for watching